in making movies sound is more than
human voices it's anything from flags
flapping in the wind to slamming doors
and crashing glass waterfalls and
lullabies every sound we can hear our
engineers can record and edit to
accommodate the storytellers wishes here
are the nominees for achievement in
sound editing
a veteran and Michael Hopkins for the
Lord the Rings at the two towers Richard
him and Gary rise from Minority Report
Scott Becker for Road to Perdition and
the Oscar goes to
Ethan van Duren and Michael Hopkins for
the Lord of the Rings the tower
this is the first Academy Award and
first nomination for Ethan bandura and
Michael Hawkins
there's so much insanity in the world
right now we feel particularly blessed
to work with such a tight-knit and
talented group of people in Wellington
New Zealand they've all poured their
heart and soul into making this movie
and become a family in that process and
we share this award with with all of you
and we want to thank a few of you yes
they're like to think at Peter Jackson
and friend whoop Walsh for this amazing
sort of you know vision the head we want
to thank Barry Osborne and marker deskey
for your tenacity and and what - thank
you Chris Ward and Angie Rose Doherty
for the unflagging a support of us rock
the way through David farmer Brent birch
Jason cannabis davidwhitehead Chris boys
Michael semantics Mike hedges thank you
all we wouldn't be here without you